zunächst einmal als ob ich mich
bestätigt fühle oder nicht ist
unerheblich ich möchte ich hatte unrecht
gab mit einigen der prognosen
ich hatte mir im übrigen von den wellen
durch assad persönlich auch mehr
erwartet dass dann gekommen ist auch nie
richtig komplett umgesetzt worden
egal also das was jetzt beschlossen
wurde ist auf jeden fall nach vorne
geblickt genau das was jetzt unbedingt
kommen muss ein harter lockdown der
realistischerweise das öffentliche leben
in schulen den betrieb in den geschäften
herunterfahren wird auf ein absolutes
minimum
und auch sehr schnell kommt somit das
ist ein richtiger sehr wichtiger
beschluss kommt wirklich keinen tag zu
früh
also ich habe jeden tag den man das
früher umsetzt ist leben gewinnt
menschen lebend und ich glaube dass also
im großen und ganzen hier also mit
augenmaß gehandelt oder aber wir hatten
auch keine zeit mehr zu verlieren
aber eine sache eine sache versteht man
nicht so richtig wenn man sich jetzt die
beschlüsse anschaut wenn die lage so
dramatisch ist wenn man sagt jeder tag
zählt warum macht man dann erst am
mittwoch dicht und hat jetzt noch
sozusagen zwei tage die möglichkeit die
einkaufsläden einzurennen und wir hören
ja bereits aus dem einzelhandel
das ist da am wochenende probleme gab ja
das ist richtig auf der anderen seite
ist es auch so einige regierungen
braucht man sozusagen
regierungssitzungen um das umzusetzen
und an einigen stellen sind auch noch
vorbereitungen zu treffen zum beispiel
wenn jetzt ab zum montag schon die
kinder zu hause sind das ist aber nichts
vorbereitet man kann das auch so eine
notfallsituation eben auf der anderen
seite ist es so ist es richtig die
früher es kommt desto besser
ich hätte mich auch gefreut wenn die
prüfung ergeben hätte das ist schon am
montag möglich ist das hätte ich auch
für besser gefunden das muss man klar
ein wann ihr wollt ich bin auch
persönlich skeptisch ob es bis zum 10
jahr neu schafft an die 10 cds von 50 zu
erreichen
und das wäre natürlich mit jedem tag man
früher begonnen hätte noch
wahrscheinlicher gewesen
herr lauterbach jetzt sind wir ja schon
eine ganze weile in dem wellenbrecher
lockt und die zahlen spiegeln das nicht
wider
wie hoch ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
wir bis zum 10 januar zumindest schon
mal eine tendenz sehen dass die zahlen
tatsächlich rapide besser werden jetzt
wo das ganze leben eigentlich komplett
runter gefahren wird ausgerechnet zur
weihnachtszeit
ja es ist ganz klar dass diese hart ich
hatte und master bewirken wird also ist
nicht die gefahr dass wir da keine
tendenzen und und dergleichen aber die
gefahr besteht natürlich insbesondere da
die regelung an weihnachten nicht
wirklich aus schließt das system leute
bloß kinder treffen das können dann
große weihnachtsfeiern sein und das
halte ich nach wie vor für falsch ich
hätte das strenger geregelt aber es war
auch weil ich also mit jedem zu machen
das birgt die gefahr dass wir nach
weihnachten noch mal einen kleinen
anstieg gekommen und das verzögert
natürlich das ende des schattens nach
hinten das ist ganz klar
ich dränge man die fall die feiertage
redet desto kürzer kann danach stand
sein und ich persönlich glaube das ist
daher alles in allem sehr
unwahrscheinlich ist dass wir am zehnten
jahr über schon überall die zehn titel
incident 52 erreicht haben
herr lauda war in den vergangenen tagen
war auch das thema impfen natürlich ein
riesiges und jetzt erleben wir dass fast
täglich länder die zulassung dass die
zulassung da ist die usa großbritannien
bahrain saudi-arabien israel alle mit
dem deutschen impfstoff warum geht das
bei uns nicht los wir haben uns
entschieden dass wir den deutschen
impfstoff und auch die anderen
impfstoffe über die europäische
zulassungsbehörde in amsterdam zu lassen
werden
dort ist die prüfung im vollen gange den
nächsten tagen abgeschlossen sein
wir haben also mental auf eine nationale
prüfung verzichtet um dem verbund mit
anderen prüfen zu können
ich würde mir auch wünschen dass man da
jetzt so ergebnissen schnell kommt
denn wir verlieren tatsächlich
mittlerweile etwas zeit und wie gesagt
man muss nach vorne blicken die gute
nachricht ist wir haben einen guten im
stoff und er kommt ausgerechnet in
deutschland daher sollte auch so schnell
wie möglich in deutschland angeboten
werden
laut aber da muss ich noch mal
nachfragen das versteht doch kein mensch
da wird in deutschland ein impfstoff
entwickelt und dann kommen israel
großbritannien usa bahrain soll
arabien und sagen wir legen los aber
deutschland nicht und dann sagen wir na
ja die ruess irgendwie schuld war die
zulassungsbehörde in amsterdam liegt
also das versteht nun wirklich kein
mensch mehr
das verfahren in der europäischen union
ist ein verfahren das etwas länger
dauert das verfahren was die länder
gewählt haben oder auch die amerikaner
und daher also ist hier mit hochdruck zu
arbeiten aber es bringt nichts jetzt das
verfahren was wir alle gewählt haben zu
kritisieren das ist daran beteilige ich
mich nicht das ist nicht meine art und
ich mein ich meine aufgabe ich blickte
nach vorn was sehr wichtig ist dass wir
die zahl wie es verstreicht dass wir die
nutzen die impfzentren gut vorzubereiten
und dass wir dann auch wirklich im
großen stil staaten rein und ich bringe
auch in erinnerung das größte problem
wird am anfang nicht die zulassung des
impfstoffes sein sondern wie viel von
dem stoff für überhaupt haben das in
probleme zu beachten und ich rechne
nicht damit dass wir deutlich mehr als
fünf millionen menschen eben von können
im ersten quartal damit auf die zweite
welle und den harten shutter und hätte
das sowieso kanada auswirkt wir sind
bild und wir liefert dir deine news auf
youtube zum nächsten video kommst du
hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren